technologies étrangères
[musique]
les algorithmes qui alimentent
la plate-forme Facebook, y compris par
exemple la fonctionnalité de recommandation la
fonctionnalité de fil d'actualité de
nouvelles preuves provenant de
documents internes de Facebook montrent que ces
technologies ne sont pas neutres en fait, elles
priorisent, promeuvent et amplifient les
types de contenu les plus nocifs et cette
enquête montre que cela comprenait l'
incitation à la violence et à la haine
contre les rohingyas
étrangers
[musique].
atteintes aux droits de l'homme dans le monde avec
ces modèles commerciaux destructeurs
[Musique]